for you man talk about fatherhood and
how uh you know
obviously you do have a lot of children
and and uh you know I've been around you
to see in a short amount of time that
you're a great father how important is
fatherhood to you
man not really big on it to be
honest what do you mean by that you're
not big on like you're I mean you're a
family man I'm here with you I see
it yeah but I'm only out I'm only like
in here cuz you here oh well I don't
believe it's a crazy topic cuz I'm not
the type like the sugar coat
n but I'm four walls all
day every day when you say four walls
you mean locked in yeah just honed in on
the music
recording you can take the that I don't
mind we B we bed a lot but mostly L
inside working no no matter if I'm
watching TV I'm just sitting there all
day
I'm stuck inside just one room I don't
really travel this house like that so
even in your own home you'll be stuck in
one
room I don't know like he wants the Hat
he can take Jason him the Hat he wants
it he can have it um so even at home you
I mean obviously we're in a beautiful
house right now you have a beautiful
home you'll still kind of just stick to
one room in the house yeah what do you
think
um why is that you think
man I don't know
I I would say I'm like I I a I wouldn't
say I'm going through a lot I'm just
me